time to turn up the heat and melt that
pool a little bit more on this home day
as we talked to
as we told you yesterday magic mike live
is coming back to the strip
just for you their new show we'll be
spicing things up with a new number
and new experiences david terry one of
the dancers of magic mike live las vegas
is joining us to tell us more hey david
rocky how's it going good good to see
you and for our viewers who haven't seen
the show and
that's me as well if you can imagine i
haven't done it yet but i look forward
to it
what can we expect kind of a little bit
of everything i mean there's there's
something for everybody there um we have
not only dancing but
uh we have acrobatics we have musicians
it's it's a good mixture everybody can
come
have a great time um feel safe doing it
um as well as there's there's some
comedy as well with our hosts
um but yeah it's it's a really fun night
out so
um and we're really excited for this new
venue as well it's gonna be twice as big
uh and have some new features that
they've kind of combined
from the london show the berlin show the
australian tour and
they're packing it all into this new
venue with the sahara so we're really
excited about
getting in there and uh work so and of
course everyone loves the original show
but what can we expect differently
from the original show this time around
so there
there are going to be for those who have
been the show we're going to keep a lot
of the same acts but then there are
going to be some new acts as well
uh there will be some surprises but we
have a lot of as i said before
new features in the venue like there's
some zip lines that go across
the um the whole theater there there are
apparatuses that will come down in
different places
it's going to be a completely new
experience channing and the team have
been working really hard
we're creating that that awesome
experience um as well as
having like a lounge outside that's
going to completely reinvent
like the theater lobby so people can
just kind of hang out before and after
the show mingle with the guys
but yeah it's it's going to be uh a
really cool 2.0 version of it so
mingle with the guys i'm sure people
love to do that i've heard people
are actually surprised to see you are
all well trained professional dancers
you mentioned channing and the team
and that's much more than just a male
review this is serious
what do you want audience to take away
from their experience
i mean i i i i do what i do just because
i want people to have
an escape and have fun and um and just
kind of forget about what's whatever's
going on in the world
at the moment and a lot of us do that's
why we perform and
a lot of us are we're tour dancers for a
lot of artists
our choreographers are all like og janet
jackson and britney spears
choreographers and dancers and
it's it's uh an amazing team to be a
part of and of course channing
um having them having him be such an
awesome kind of role model and uh and be
there for us and
yeah it's great it's a lot of fun and i
love doing what we do there so
well we are so excited is it what's the
website so people can actually get
tickets
yeah so it's magic mike live las vegas
dot com
and uh tickets go on sale this friday
and our show is going to be up march
26 2021. all right david thank you so
much that was fun i can't wait to see
the show
yes thank you so much all right speaking
of hotline